troy murdoch is a contributing editor to
national review online we are delighted
to have him join us tonight
my favorite part was when karine jumped
here i don't know if i'm pronouncing her
name correctly i don't want to be racist
um he said i'd like to change the
subject for a minute and then called
someone else racist that seems like the
only subject really it seems like the
only one thank you thank you very active
racism and having me here tonight tucker
but yeah look when you have nothing else
to talk about you don't have any answers
or any actual solutions might work you
scream racism uh another thing that
screaming racism does it's a very polite
or maybe somewhat more polite of saying
polite way of saying shut the hell up uh
they don't want the conversation they
don't want the tough questions they
don't want anything else in terms of
constructive criticism so you scream
racism that's designed not to advance
the conversation but to shut it down and
to go back to what you were saying in
your excellent monologue earlier about
venezuela i happened to visit venezuela
a couple times the late 90s early zeros
and yes it was a prosperous prosperous
place fun place beautiful place and it's
a total wreck and uh in order to keep us
from turning into that country which we
seem to be with the empty empty uh store
shelves the climbing prices uh baby
formula shortage babies in the hospital
because of this formula shortage
unbelievable uh joe biden could fix a
lot of problems inflation
his political woes which are terrible
the political standing for the
democratic party by saying look i made a
big mistake by shining on the keystone
pipeline we need to increase domestic
oil production begin to start bringing
energy prices down if energy prices
start to come down the rest the price
curve would come down inflation would
ease to a degree and i think if people
at least saw inflation going down uh
confidence would improve uh optimism
would increase and things people start
feeling a lot better but right now every
time i turn on the tv gas prices going
up up and away every every day a higher
a record price for gas and diesel now
there's talk about diesel shortages
coming and as you say this place in in
less than a year and a half at the 15 16
months is looking a lot more like it's
beginning a lot begin to look a lot more
like venezuela than anything you and i
or anybody ever could imagine the
concern is not just poverty but
radicalism i mean no one's getting more
moderate so
refusing to address people's legitimate
concerns calling them racist if they ask
honest questions
all of that makes people more radical
over time are you worried that the
country could you know you can kind of
feel it moving underneath your feet here
another that's what i think a lot of
people in the far far left want you know
i think one of the greatest political
slogans was that of of vladimir lenin
before the russian revolution it was
very very simple four words the worse
the better the worse the better the
worse the conditions were more people
would be radicalized and say look we've
had it with the czar maybe we should
bring a lenin and maybe you can turn
things around i think there's some
people who want total utter chaos in
society i have a piece in the american
spectator about the democratic party and
how they have nothing but terrible ideas
awful solutions and some of the people
in the far left democrat party today i
think want exactly that kind of chaos
and ultimately a revolutionary type
situation
the worst the better boy that is that is
chilling joy murdoch thank you so much
tucker great to see you thank you you
too
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight